hey this is presh talwalkar
if e equals 8 find the numerical value
of the following expression
this problem appeared as part of the mit
entrance exam in 1869
at the time they would have had limited
mathematical typography so this was
written as an inline expression
if it is difficult for you to understand
the expression let me present the modern
formatting of this expression
can you figure it out
remember to use only pen and paper there
were no handheld calculators in 1869
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the first thing we'll do is we'll
substitute the value e equals eight
so wherever we see the variable e we
will replace it with eight
we now have a mathematical expression
that we need to calculate
we have various operations in this
expression and we will need to do them
according to the order of operations
these are rules about precedence in
which we should evaluate different
operations
we have parentheses brackets then
exponent orders then multiplication
division and finally addition and
subtraction if we have two operators of
the same precedence then you should
evaluate them from left to right
this single expression actually tests
all of these rules
so we'll get started with parentheses
and brackets
we have two different parenthetical
expressions and we'll evaluate the first
one on the left
now within this parenthetical expression
we also have the square root which could
be treated like an exponent
so we have the square root of eight plus
one
the square root also has an implied
grouping of eight plus one
so we'll first evaluate eight plus one
is equal to nine
we now have the square root of nine
which is equal to three
we now return to our parenthetical
expression and we have three plus two
which is equal to five
we'll now evaluate the other
parenthetical expression
in this one we also have a cube root
which we need to evaluate first the cube
root of eight is equal to two
we know it eight minus two which is
equal to six
we now have an expression and we need to
evaluate the square root which is
eight minus four
so again we have an implied grouping of
eight minus four
so we take eight minus four and we have
the square root of four
the square root of four is equal to two
now we have a multiplication that we
need to evaluate first
this is six times two which is equal to
twelve
finally we have a subtraction and an
addition we have eight minus five and we
have five plus twelve
some people are not sure whether to do
the addition or the subtraction first
this is where the rule that if you have
operations of the same precedence you
can evaluate them from left to right
so we'll take the left operation first
eight minus five is equal to three
and then we have three plus twelve which
is equal to 15.
and that's our answer
that expression ultimately evaluates to
be 15.
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description